the jurogan experience i'd even won snl
i didn't want snl now you and i both
know
that was uh nobody came out of going
that's the greatest
gig it's very rarely people came out
they come out like they were in a fight
absolutely like they just got out of a
[ __ ] bar fight
exactly that's how phil hartman was when
i first started working with phil
hartman in 94 he had just left
snl and he it took a while for him to be
comfortable around
us like the news radio people the actors
were super friendly everybody liked to
get hammered that was like the big thing
we would get
[ __ ] blasted drunk yeah but we were
all like
really like in terms of like actors
genuinely supportive like dave foley was
the most supportive guy ever
like he was always writing jokes for you
he was always like
rewriting scenes for you like jim come
in and say this instead
well he would write like really great
lines but
phil was like he look he was in a
competition at first
he thought like everybody was going to
be competing then he once he relaxed
feel like smoke weed and once he relaxed
he's like you know going on over there
was like everything was like doggy dog
and everybody's
at each other's throats it's dog-eat-dog
it's and there's no rhyme or reason yeah
there's no rhyme or reason it's it's
just like politics
in other words i can't help with
congress what bill they're gonna pass
even they know even they know this is
gonna work nope
same kind of stuff it's the same exact
thing because you're fighting to get
your bits on right you're fighting to
get your pieces on you're fine to get
your your little
sketches on yeah and the worst the
the worst part is you know something's
gonna work
and you have someone come to you towards
the end it made me such a dark human
being
because i i'm the hey man let's all
yeah let's all be a team and i used to
when i when i worked with hats i said
let's look at this roster
holy crap let's see who goes in the
boston comedy club
let's just buy a script and put everyone
in it and let them play to their
strength wow
you know this one i'm like i wish i had
the business smarts
to go back and do that because you're
it would have been it would have been so
much fun
i mean maybe it would have been disaster
maybe this guy maybe i would end up
getting leather pants so i got my
[ __ ] white lion
leather pants but it makes you so
you know i i i don't want to better
never you never got memories you never
got bitter but you understood that
bitterness is an option correct and i
start smoking an intense amount of
pot yeah just to numb myself i remember
when you told me you quit you're like
dude i'm hearing voices i think the
government's following me
you went so far i went far
i would jim quit and but then i talked
to like oh he might have went into never
never land he went he went
to the land of no return well when you
start thinking that the government is
watching you
nonstop non-stop they're honoring me
because they know i
think by myself
it's like the scene in goodfellas the
goddamn [ __ ] helicopter i [ __ ]
love that scene
but um i will say this
um yeah i have have you returned to the
fold
i haven't returned the way i have in the
past
but a little bit but i have i have uh
you will never
see me it's very private
you have you're a private weed smoker
yeah
how does that work in other words i
don't do it with people anymore because
it keeps the paranoia away
because i don't trust anyone oh i don't
trust anyone i still
don't and i haven't smoked smoked i like
i went a bit i went out to colorado and
the five little milligrams and the
tenderloin fives are nice those little
edibles oh my god
five's nice yes just have that yeah
and then have like a martini
martini extra dirty not too dirty i like
it dirty
i like it i like it not crazy dirty but
a little dirty a little dirty
i like that olive juice it's delicious i
do too so
here's what happened my wife this is why
this is why my wife's a powerhouse she
when you find someone that don't give a
[ __ ] about the industry
and they only care about you it's very
hard
as as an artist that's chasing a star
because you're always chasing the star
and you're always chasing the mansion
she would go i'll never forget she's
like why you just quit
like i seriously are you stupid you
don't quit
santa live the hell is she and she's
like look at you
you come home you're miserable they
control everything
they steal your ideas this one stole
i saw my own two eyes how they treated
you in this
how did they steal your ideas here we go
i'll give you i'm sure you don't want to
get high first
let's go take a pee break let's take a
p-ring
no here's and again i've released all
this
okay you know i got a strong moral
backbone i'm good
so no i don't have any bad feelings what
happened was and i'm not going to put
out
i don't want to hash names and all that
but what would happen is something like
this
you're writing a sketch and then one of
the head writers
would come in in the doorway and go
hey i see you're writing a sketch about
blah blah blah because we have the main
server and we check
everyone's sketches i just want to let
you know i'm writing the same thing
he goes you can continue yours but you
know
i'm in the room with lauren i'm just
whoa
oh yeah so this is that so they would go
onto the server they would see the
sketches that you're writing
and then then there was then there was
times where
a cast member would come in and look at
look at my board and go
oh what does that mean like oh that's
that's a that's a sketch and i know so
and so has come in
and i know the ratings are going to be
high that week so i'm waiting to bring
my a stuff
for that everyone's going to come out
their fangs out when this one's on
so i'm going to save that sketch
for when they're on and then this person
would ask me
oh my god what exactly i said well i'm
gonna take it out of its element
you know like for like i was back then i
was like peshy i'm like
pesky is gonna read to children about
rudolph the red-nosed reindeer and tell
explain why his nose is red
and the big joke is because he's a rat
and and i compared to a whole
neighborhood
he's a rat that's why his nose is red
when you go
and so you end up beating certain kids
moba
the next week the whole room is set
and and you're sitting there and then
this person
you know lauren goes next sketch is uh
you know
al pacino or scarface reading to school
children
rudolph the red-nosed reindeer and you
go
you you you and you look you see their
their eyes are down
you know what's going on you know what
happened you can't say anything
well when you say something which i
eventually did
dude i think i may be and i want to
challenge all
snl cast and writers i
may be the last one that threatened
violence
i was in i was in a room with one of the
guys
and i literally said i will knock your
[ __ ] teeth down your [ __ ] throat
you [ __ ]
if you don't want to [ __ ] be here get
the [ __ ] out you don't [ __ ] on my [ __ ]
cause you don't want to [ __ ]
oh dude whoa and i was
and i told him i'll knock him the [ __ ]
knock his [ __ ] teeth down
i'm not i'm not from the writing world
so that's where that place brought me
wow and so
and that particular instance was see now
i'm getting all over that's gotta be
coming from the top down
because the when when i got alone with
philip phil and i became close
and you know we would hang out together
especially in his his dress room we had
a nice dressing room had it all set up
had a guitar looking at his aviation
books and [ __ ] and
he would uh we would talk about his time
there and he's like it just
made me that's just bitter and angry yes
yeah but it seems like it's always been
that way that it's been from the top
down and and this particular year were
you on
95 to 98 so you were on right after phil
left
yeah because i was with phil in 94. and
so
when that person did that i then went up
to them and i waited
and i was like you [ __ ] he goes
i didn't
no i didn't take it now this one also
is getting more air time because they're
in with this specific head writer
and then the head writer comes to me hey
man leave him alone
i go hey man stop him from stealing
well you know i don't care what he does
just leave him alone during my sketches
like why you do so you're it's like
you're in
high school and so yeah it's it it makes
you
and then here i remember doing something
where i played
a drunk guy and i didn't know exactly
how to do it but i i always wanted to be
another foster brooks
so long story short i want to do another
foster brooks type thing so i did the
character i'm not a great writer i'm not
a good writer at all
um but like i'll come up the character
and try to
eat and if we could put it in somewhere
great
and i remember the writer coming up
saying yeah lauren doesn't like uh
drunks because you know the past and
john and blah blah blah oh okay and then
two weeks later
john belushi yeah i guess that's what he
meant and then
two weeks later it's the drunk character
like what dude what the
it's just it's little things that mind
screw you like that
so by the time the big the big finale
was
towards the end you know someone told me
you know what sandler did sandlin went
through this everyone went through this
comedians go through this
what you got to do is get on the update
and you gotta get
in the uh do everything you can to go on
the update and everything again
opening monologue because the head
writers can't mess with you
because that's that's not really their
departure so crazy
that that's something you have to think
about so then that's why i started doing
it if you notice in 98 i started getting
more
monologues and then even there they were
like we got this
and then it was uh a final monologue it
was matthew broderick
and it was when matthew broadwork was on
and he he couldn't get through some of
the sketches i was doing with him he'd
start laughing
and so when we went to he really wanted
to do this monologue with me
and this one these these particular head
writers were like no
we're not doing it although matthew was
like i want to do gems
i want to do jim and tracy's and
there was two three sketches we had
together and he laughed
during the dress like he couldn't keep
straight fast and then i remember the
head this particular writer had a
problem with
i never probably just didn't like
whatever you had a hard-on for me
whatever
i i can't i don't i don't understand ego
if you got an ego that is what it is
and he said um yeah it's too bad he
laughed because now we don't know if it
works so that's going to be caught in
this cut and
you listen we filmed the monologue
it worked but we're gonna go with my
monologue during the air show
i was like you know what man i'm gonna
talk to lauren he goes no you're not i
said no i'm
i'm talking to lauren now i'm not afraid
to talk to lauren anymore because that's
an author it's like you know i'll
talk to the president don't talk to the
president they put this
so he would say no you're not you're
going to talk to lauren 100
we'll talk to him what no we'll both go
talk to him and then that's
i knew right from that minute i was done
i knew it was done and then that summer
this guy named uh gary considine
he ran the tonight show and he said jim
what happened dude i said what's the
matter he goes so-and-so and so and so
are are really same
you're out no really
i go well tell you what i don't want to
be there anymore my wife's like just
please quit it's just you said in your
life
if any job no matter how much money it
paid
makes you a miserable human being and
changes the person you are
you weren't going to work there it's
like look at you you're
angry all the time you smoke pot all the
time to numb yourself
you you're not jim anymore where's the
goofy
uplifting gym and i wanted to
i wanted i feel like you're so stupid
but
too bad but she was so smart
she was so smart and it was the greatest
and i give
lorne a lot of credit because
lauren said to me um jim
you're too nice for this business wow
and he said
which i'll never forget there's a couple
things lauren said and i never blamed
lauren i always really admired lauren
i said uh oh he goes
and if you ever want want to do
something i'm your producer i'll produce
it for you
which i never took that opportunity up
but i'll never forget when he said that
to me so i was very
thankful that he was understanding and
let me go
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience